as more people get vaccinated it's
important to point out that the shots
do not mean complete immunity instances
of people getting the virus after
getting the vaccine are called
breakthrough cases
so while it is unusual in clark county
nearly a dozen of those cases have been
fatal
argo manna live tonight with concerns
within the community
denise and brian experts say everyone
needs to be extra careful right now
even people who are fully vaccinated
they add that in light of breakthrough
cases and the delta variant
contact tracing is crucial maybe now
more than ever
it's really on the rise right now covet
concerns in clark county as
cases climb i ended up getting a las
vegas woman who wanted to remain
anonymous says she was about to get the
vaccine a couple weeks ago
but then she contracted the virus
another member of her household has a
breakthrough infection which means she's
fully vaccinated but still got coveted
as of right now the southern nevada
health district is reporting a total of
70 breakthrough hospitalizations
and 11 breakthrough deaths in clark
county it's not
something you want to hear still in most
cases those with a breakthrough
infection have mild symptoms
she bounced back a little bit quicker
than i did both got this text message
from the health district as part of
contact tracing
in a statement to 8 news now snhd said
quote the southern nevada health
district has continued to do contact
tracing throughout the pandemic the
contact tracing system works the same
way even if someone is already
vaccinated
hot spots are not publicized but experts
say with breakthrough cases and the
delta variant in the mix
we may need to rethink that if we can
really pinpoint
one specific event and we think that
there are multiple people that are
impacted
at that point we may want to notify the
public and due to large mask-less indoor
gatherings
you really should get tested because
even if you're vaccinated
experts add the vaccines are still our
best protection
i think the vaccine is doing hopefully
what it's supposed to do
now the cdc and the southern nevada
health district have not
updated mass guidance but the expert i
spoke to today says
it's still a good idea even if you're
fully vaccinated especially
if you're with a large crowd inside
reporting live in las vegas tonight orco
mana 8 news now